[Music]
i once had the opportunity to audition
for frank oz
who directed the muppet movie he
directed many of my favorite movies what
about bob dirty rotten scoundrels he's a
legend to me he also happened to do many
of the voices of the muppets i'm not
great at auditions and i uh but i found
myself getting even more nervous than i
usually do i i was getting almost like
scared i realized that he sounded
exactly like one of the muppets he
played with sam the eagle and sam the
eagle was a character uh on the muppet
show that i was terrified of he was this
bald eagle that read the news and he was
very authoritative and like frank's
natural speaking voice and i think
that's why i was kind of regressing back
to a childhood state of being afraid i
used to have to leave the room when sam
the eagle would come on and at one point
he started laughing he said something
like i really liked when you did that
thing there
and he kind of laughed like that and i
realized oh my god that's yoda or miss
piggy and it made me feel so much
better maybe it's funny to confuse yoda
and miss piggy
such different they're such different
voices i know but if they have similar
if you listen to them similar
they have similar like
their face looks so crazy
my eyebrows you look like uh pee-wee
herman laughing when you do that
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your host huh justin long life could be
a dream sweetheart
[Music]
and with me as always my brother
christian who you do a pretty good pee
wee herman impression i was doing it the
other day and i'm now i'm forgetting how
i did it it was like it's like it was
like you know
listen cherry uh yeah it was like
i don't know what you're saying
yeah it's like kind of like [ __ ]
like pee wee herman in uh pee wee's big
adventure is like i don't want to do
that i
listen sofa yeah
yeah
it's like he's just like like a [ __ ]
isn't he
uh i just think that's how he comes
across
he's [ __ ]
i don't think he says necessarily [ __ ]
thing is he does he i'm trying to
remember i haven't seen it in a while i
don't have it either but
listen sophie sofa i have a problem
exactly no one took my bike you see i
think that i think you're right i think
that might have just been his voice but
now because i haven't seen it in so long
my memory of the whole character is
colored by that voice yeah my memory of
him is that he was like kind of a [ __ ]
character i don't think he was i don't
think he was i don't i don't think he
yeah you're right the the quality of his
voice suggests that he complained a lot
but i don't think he did i think he was
really like he was sweet sweet to his
friends and stuff he's like he had
friends that were
furniture large merged
yeah i'm only remembering that he
someone took his bike and i remember
when i saw that as a kid it was really
traumatic to me that like the large
margin in the trunk remember that was
terrifying it's tim burton i used to not
be able to watch that that scene that
was terrifying like you with sam the
eagle i could not watch that large march
scene
speaking of pee-wee herman our guest
we gotta get on with the show so [ __ ]
uh our guest today has um has a very
similar i would say laugh oh my god
frank oz i can't believe we're
attempting to segue from what we're
talking about now it says to me it's
when i heard
your impression of frank oz's laugh i
was the first thing i thought of
really it doesn't it doesn't mean it
does actually and a little bit like
the nutty professor okay so our guest
today there's no smooth way to do this
there's no this is we've this is not
going to be a good segue but uh our
guest today is the esteemed uh brilliant
neil degrasse tyson
by far the classiest guest i think we've
had on this show degrasse would i say
degrasse oh
i think you were thinking degrassi i was
i was
already i messed i'm totally messed up
nail degrasse
tyson he's esteemed he's um undoubtedly
when we we met him neither of us had met
him before and there's something about
being in his presence that you felt like
you were in the presence of
greatness yeah but yet as imposing as i
thought he would be and
he's big physically he's a large person
yes and as uh he's huge kind of
intimidating as his presence is it's so
disarming because he couldn't have been
more
jovial
friendly and down to earth i know he any
danger of us being
nervous as a result of that large
presence and large stature um
both his mind and his his body uh and
really like down to yeah i was stunned
somebody with that kind of intellect
he's also somewhat responsible i think
for uh pluto being downsized from
planetary status yeah sorry plute heads
uh but he is and a lot of people come to
him for answers he's that he's that well
known as a as an intellect one of our
great intellects he's written several
best-selling books but the one he was
here primarily to talk about is the one
that's called letters from an
astrophysicist and
justin and i were recently on a road
trip from florida up the coast to
connecticut and
we received a copy an uh on audible of
his book um to listen to on the trip
thank god we did i was shocked by how
accessible it was i mean
he talks about obviously very heady
things in the book um a lot of most of
these letters are are
very intense but
he is brilliant at making things seem
uh
digestive yeah yeah with the audience to
it like uh at i would say we're we would
count as average it's called
astrophysics for dummies
no it's called um letters to an
astrophysicist letters from an
astrophysicist oh i thought letters too
from i was right letters from an
astrophysicist it could also be called
letters to an astrophysicist because
these physicist
because uh and they're all real letters
written by uh real people ranging from
all different walks of life uh there's a
once a seven-year-old a kid writes in
an inmate writes in who's only nine
no the inmate's an adult
but but from all different
experience levels and and approaches and
backgrounds uh and it's it's just
incredible the way he's able to navigate
each of these questions uh
and like we said some of which are very
most of which are very heavy um
and he's just a brilliant communicator
we talk about that and you'll hear it in
in the episode what a great speaker he
is what a great voice he has uh i wasn't
that familiar with it um
prior to
listening to this book it's still weird
for me to say listening to this book we
get into that uh he's really cool and
you guys uh hopefully we'll stick around
and hear how cool he is and affable and
down to earth and what a great and what
a better communicator he is than both of
us put together oh my god it's such an
understatement so coming up
justin's chit chat with the great [ __ ]
neil degrasse tyson life could be a
dream sweetheart
[Music]
i bet you have to go to a special well
so nowadays you know sort of big and
tall the problem is big and talls are
not centered on fashion
all right it's just it's just we'll wrap
a cloth around here yeah a moomoo is
fine
exactly yeah we have a lovely tablecloth
over here exactly
so there's finally a place called
rochester which is around 6th avenue
their centerline design is for bigger
men with bigger limbs and everything
so that it looks good you're not just
the extreme of some other design right
it's centered on it but it's really
expensive
i shop at that uh little and petite
men's store oh no um is that a thing
yeah it's a new thing yeah so it's very
expensive as well uh i have a similar
problem um i just listened to your book
on the way back from a road trip we were
in florida we were going up the uh the
east coast and
it really struck me what a
great communicator you were why didn't
which ironically i wasn't able to say
that that was available over your words
you are very what's the word uh
articulate um the book is called letters
from an astrophysicist and and
you did listen to oh yeah god i love you
you know what one of the
i would call it a feature of the book in
audio form is that we were able to use
voice actors for the letters yeah very
well you know novels that are read
there's the question do you have
different characters reading different
characters right different voices but
usually it's one voice reading a whole
novel right they put a little twist in
the voice just to distinguish some of
the characters here it's a fully
legitimate bring in the voices oh it was
great give me a kid voice a female voice
a gruff voice a southern voice yeah a
far invoice fascinating these
correspondents and they range from as
you said children i mean there was a
seven-year-old who was uh i love how
many people are mad at you about pluto
yeah
i just what i really want to say is get
over it yeah but no
that's a less eloquent letter that's the
evil neil from the evil universe who
says that
uh but yeah that was in the in the hate
mail section oh yeah that's the chapter
yeah
uh angry elementary school children yeah
that i want to hear i was a visible
exponent of it but i was really just an
accessory i i didn't pull the trigger oh
oh okay in terms of uh so you didn't
demoting pluto yeah yeah yeah we we were
very visible about it yeah up at the uh
hayden planetarium where we rebuilt the
place we said we were early out of the
box but the trend line the writing was
already really on the wall and what
constituted that for an idiot like me
why oh well we always knew pluto didn't
quite fit in it was a little small
and across the orbit of sounds like me
in school
yeah but did you cross other orbits
uh you crossed in the orbit of another
planet that's just wrong oh oh oh no
that that's just not very taboo yeah oh
no
what are you doing oh you don't do that
don't do that not for a red-blooded
planet and
other things there were a lot of other
craggy chunks of ice and rock
orbiting in its vicinity
so it didn't really own its orbit oh
interesting and so we came up the
community came up with a
a new definition of a planet in fact
planets had never really been defined
before so there was a new thing to do
this uh
never been defined unambiguously so are
you large enough to be round because
small
objects tend to be craggy like asteroids
look like idaho potatoes or something
round like spherical are you large
enough gravity will make you round
yes pluto is round yes but
um have you cleared your orbit of other
objects
and pluto the answer is no
so it is not a full red-blooded planet
it's a dwarf planet and and neil had
that been part of the definition of
planet prior to your uh oh no no no
planets didn't really
in fact we used to have seven planets
in ancient times and those seven planets
were mercury venus mars jupiter saturn
the sun and the moon
this is where you get this seven days of
the week
the seven names for the days of the week
derive from those seven objects what is
monday from the moon sundays from the
sun right um saturday saturn yeah right
this is where you get these and you mix
the norse and
sorry i mean thursday's thor's day
but
thor what's thor's counterpart in greek
in roman legend it's zeus no it's not
zeus jupiter
okay so if you look at thursday in
romance languages
it's jupiter it's the word for jupiter
basically so that's how you got the
names for the seven days then we
realized no
everything doesn't go around earth
everything goes around the sun
so overnight
and the moon goes around earth and pluto
of course was from the but it wasn't
discovered yet okay so
at that point the sun is not a planet
you can't call the sun a planet right
you can't call the moon a planet
that's right so then we went from seven
down to
six
the six planets were mercury venus earth
mars jupiter saturn then we discovered
uranus them uranus uranus well i can't
maybe your anus but it's my uranus well
see i'm amazed that you were the first
to go there
[Laughter]
for sure
i was trying to stay off and it'd be
classy you're my classiest guest you you
tested the water
so
uranus neptune and then those were
discovered in the last 300 years and
pluto was discovered in 1930. oh my god
fully expecting it to be a red-blooded
planet and as the years went on we said
no it's not as big as we thought well
how big is it we don't know yet let's
keep testing it and we now know that our
moon has five times the mass of pluto
oh yeah pluto lovers generally don't
know this little like the seven-year-old
who wrote to you you should have said
that to her her her gripe was that um
other people on pluto or whoever
inhabited yes she was she was worried
that the people who have if people lived
on pluto they won't exist anymore yes
yeah and and that's an example of how i
mean it sounds silly but you actually
respond in a very
rational
kind thoughtful way and you're not at
all condescending or
listen little girl it's very like as you
are with everyone right thanks for
noticing that and every letter in there
no matter how absurd on the surface the
question sounds
i'm giving the person full attention and
full sort of rational
foundations for a conversation one of
them is uh could there be a big hairy
ape wandering the pacific northwest yes
that was one of the questions yes yeah i
loved your rants and i gave you know i
said you know
while we are discovering new species
each year they tend to be like microbial
yeah yes or insects or some poison arrow
frogs
yeah something that is just not as big
as you're saying yeah and by the way
when the before earth was mapped we were
discovering big creatures all the time
yeah yeah it's like what is this oh
that's an elephant or that so this or
the grape fauna from great fauna exactly
so
but that guy if i'm not mistaken wrote
back
and here's the thing i'm having this
conversation with him he writes back and
says
for someone smart you you seem really
closed-minded i thought you'd be more
open-minded than this yeah
then i went down in the trenches with
him and i said
if it's a big hairy ape it presumably
reproduces sexually and it should have
at least two of them yeah a male and a
female a
b
you shouldn't only be looking for an ape
look for his bones look for his poop yes
i love the way you said poop by the way
he says but you say put and you do your
own you read obviously your own side of
the letter yes
yes people can now hear you have a great
voice well dinner knows you have 15
shoes
massive um speaking of bigfoot
but i love that you said poop and you
said it emphatically uh but yeah i guess
his point was that oh the pacific
northwest is there's so much he said
three million acres whatever the number
is huge but if you're that big you get
around
yes exactly and this now i'm thinking of
the sexual component of two big feats
making love uh and making a baby bigfoot
yes and so it would just be
well so i think how i ended it was
you're better off
using energy
to find bigfoot and present him as
evidence rather than trying to convince
me that he exists in the absence of
evidence exactly it was a great answer
and so true and and again very patient i
think that's why thank you thank you for
noticing that not everyone notices that
well the best teachers i ever had were
patient with you did you need patients i
did i do absolutely and you you say this
at one point my dad was a teacher i grew
up my older brother's a teacher and so i
grew up early what the hell happened to
you i know right
black sheep yeah where did that come
from your ability to communicate did you
have
a mentor
a specific person that you emulated that
you you looked at and thought i wanna i
wanna be like this person that's a great
question and i gotta go back one step
before that and say that i have an
unorthodox
outlook on role models
i think a role model is a misguided
concept because it forces you
to find a whole person
that has a similar background as you
with the similar ambition that you had
and you're trying to match too much
if i needed a role model who was a black
person who came before me in the bronx
who became an astrophysicist i'd take
your picture
instead i assembled my role models a la
carte
so what i did was i said well there's
somebody who has an amazing agility with
words
and i said wow i want to one day be able
to communicate
with that facility
not only just with words but you just
wanted to keep hearing them talk
because they were their voice was
soothing and they said interesting
things and it was laced with some humor
let me say lace that sounds like it's
drugs yeah it was infused with humor so
that every few sentences you smiled and
that kept you interested what a rare it
took for rare i said i want some of that
then i met a scientist who had such a
command of content and there i am 15 and
the guy is 50 and i'm saying i will
never know that much about the universe
not thinking how many more years i had
to actually study the stuff
and i said but if i ever become a
scientist i want the command of the
content the way he has
and i think they never left my head and
then uh my parents were very
progressive in almost every outlook your
mother was a lawyer no no no no she was
a a gerontologist she was a homemaker
while we were in school we were pseudo
almost empty nest and then she went back
to school oh wow finished her degrees
got a master's in gerontology then
worked for the feds allocating the
health the department of health and
human services uh allocating monies for
nursing homes and old age care centers
and that sort of thing my father
was active in the civil rights movement
yes so everybody's caring about people
and this is their son the astrophysicist
yeah so i stayed grounded but in a in a
morally correct way i mean not grounded
i can't reach for the stars yes reach
for this for the stars but don't forget
earth
so this is the environment so how did
they how did they communicate that they
didn't by just by being what they were
either example oh yeah was there
religion in your home so i was raised
catholic
you know catholics have a very wide
range of who observes what's going on
yes and you touch on this several times
yeah in fact there's many letters in
there on religion god and spirituality
this is where people's angst has been
centered yeah you do say that over you
you use the term overflowing with
existential angst which i love
for people yeah trying to understand
their place in the world and many of
them were raised in a religious
tradition and then they're confronted
with science and and then they worried
will they lose their religion so all of
this is in there the different letters
scattered in different ways some are
more more orthodox than others i'm
correct my upbringing was my my dad was
in the seminary for seven years we were
very so he he has a
real respect for the catholic tradition
um but it's not as dogmatic right
exactly
in my family it was that way as well i
think the question one needs to ask if
you're religious
is
not did you go to synagogue every
saturday or pray five times a day or go
to church on sundays i think a different
question would be
in your everyday life
what role did religion play in decisions
you make and thoughts you had for me it
was essentially zero
from third grade onward there were no
thoughts about god or jesus or anything
and did that coincide with the time that
you really discovered you began to
understand science yeah i began to
understand the nature of the universe
yeah and i would ask questions can god
see me if i'm not near a window you know
i'm in third grade when i'm asking these
questions but how could he create the
whole universe and then pay attention i
started just asking questions and it
became less and less tenable to me yeah
since it was not folded into family
decisions at no time to my mother or
father said what would jesus do we were
raised secularly my brother and my
sister so you were in the middle no no
i'm the problem middle child
that's where you're going isn't it it's
the one thing we have in common yeah
but i tell you just quick
i met someone afresh and they said based
on my my personality as they read it in
the first five minutes of knowing me
they said oh you must be an eldest child
i said no
oh then you must be the youngest child
no but then i guess you're the only
child and i said no and they said well
what are you and i saw i'm the middle
child oh that explains yeah myself it's
like i'm sorry
there's no there's nothing left yeah
yeah the permutation that's such a good
example of a lot of those letters that
people are looking to answer something
they've already come together looking to
verify verify yeah exactly and so that's
that's harder to reply to because people
have already made up their minds when
you make that distinction you have to
make it in several different forms
throughout these letters uh the
difference between believing in
something science is not something you
believe in science is something that is
uh it requires a set of
you know empirical truths that's right
that's right and that's why collectively
religions are called faiths yeah yeah
faith is something you believe in the
absence of evidence if you had evidence
you call it science yes yeah it's kind
of that simple and some people like to
reduce science to a faith-based thing in
order to make their argument for the
religion that happens a few times oh
right right yeah i'll restate that
because you say that very quickly and
it's a very important thing that you
just said there are many people who want
to say
science is just as much of a religion as
religion is right and they'll say
because you guys have paradigms and you
guys have belief systems and you all
band together and you and it's like
no that's not how that works just just
visit a scientific conference in any
discipline where everyone is on the
frontier we are arguing we are fighting
there's no name calling and generally we
don't break into fist fights i'd love to
see that though
two scientists pocket protector fights
but but i'm just saying it is our job
yeah to find the holes in someone's talk
if you do not engage in that exercise
you are being irresponsible as a
colleague right it's it's so it's far
more so to say it's subject to change is
an understatement
on the frontier it changes every day but
once you achieve correspondence between
your research and my research and
someone in another country and someone
who used a different voltage for their
experiment you look at the variations in
how the experiments are conducted
experiments of different design if they
all lean the same direction
in the same way
approximately to the same results you
have a new objective truth in the world
you put it in the textbook and you move
on to the next thing and i thought that
was interesting in in uh in the context
of the 9 11 conspiracies you touch on
this and that you were yeah there's some
there's
right i mean you're hitting every hot
point there in the book yeah i i i take
on uh cons conspiracy theorists the
difference was this person was not sort
of full up conspiracy theorist it was
like look i've been hanging around these
guys yeah i wonder if they have a point
what do you say yeah so that was fair he
really wanted to know they're totally
yeah and oftentimes i mean some are very
moving too some are incred some are
about you know the ones about life and
death people who are experiencing death
and and you say something that's a whole
chapter yeah called life and death yeah
right yeah um
people who are themselves dying or
or in a bereavement over a loved one who
has died and and will they see them in
heaven you know there's
these questions and they keep me awake
and these are the ones right and just
you might think listening to this
conversation that here are these people
bearing their souls and i just stomp on
it with my oh god with my feet but what
here's my one bit of evidence that
that's not what happens here
is one of the letters it's a jewish
woman raising a ten-year-old son who is
on the autism spectrum
he comes home
from hebrew school one day and says he
doesn't believe in god
anymore and that he doesn't believe in
the bible stories and she's orthodox
jewish and so she says how did you get
these ideas and he says
cosmos oh god oh great okay so now i'm
indeed what's this cosmo
right right so all right
i was afraid to keep reading neil what
who what to do
i would have a talk with this mr tyson
right right right so at the end she says
you know i respect my son and i don't
want to force him to believe something
that might not be true
that she said could god and science
coexist
and i just want to know i know he
respects you and i thank you for that
she's very it's a very
it's a very respectful letter
and at the end she says i'm just trying
to be a good parent it took me a year to
reply because there was how am i going
to come into that i don't know let me
put it down she's orthodox jewish i've
done a lot of homework on religions yeah
people ask me and rather than just
discounted i'm saying let me let me know
enough about their religion to at least
have some sensitivity to where they're
coming from well you also say that
you've exposed your children to many
religions yes from a more
anthropological perspective yeah this is
a people believe this they believe that
and here's why that was their savior and
this is there i finally wrote back wow
and i wrote back on passover oh i
figured that bro
yeah when she's checking her email
i'm not going to tell you what i wrote
in the letter it's in the book okay but
i will say
that she did reply
thanked me for the letter
and
invited me to her son's bar mitzvah and
no kidding yes tell me you went no i i
didn't feel comfortable plus i had a
busy schedule i couldn't make it but i'm
giving a public talk in atlanta where
she lives so i invited them to come oh
that's i will meet them for the first
time that's nice i was also struck by
that uh listening to this book it's
weird to say listening to this book
reading this book but i didn't
technically read it um this is what i
really admire one of the things i
admire you so much uh for is your
ability to
do that you're the thought that you put
into that because that when it comes to
teaching i mean that is that is as
it's as important as the stuff you know
i would imagine i learned this from my
father yeah because he taught uh he
talked to sociology in bronx community
college before he went to work for he
worked for the mayor right the mayor
yeah for mayor lindsay that's correct uh
in the 1960s so
where are you born are you in fairfield
connecticut it's my dad talking okay so
you're you're in the region yeah yeah
yeah so what did he teach he touched
philosophy
yeah so i want to get to that oh my gosh
i know yeah yeah so uh where did he
teach philosophy at fairfield university
it was a small cheshire school in
connecticut okay cool very cool yeah
jesuits so they
prosecuted galileo yes hold me back oh
yeah
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondery plus in
apple podcasts or the wandery app
[Music]
hello hello
we'll meet again
his field was more medieval philosophy
so it was cool yeah cool and
again medieval times it's i just want to
know
why
yes yes i don't know
is that so wrong
no you must want to know where and the
evolution of that thought you know uh
you you touch on that in the i think the
philosophy section is how you talk about
bertrand russell and how philosophy has
had to evolve
based on what we're discovering right
in all fairness to professional
philosophers that chapter i really it's
called philosophy but i really should
have called it questions that really
didn't fit any other chapter someone
says one asks about the difference
between how and why yes yes and i said
that we got to call that philosophy yes
that's not astrophysics it's not that
was fast
right so so that's why it's not as sexy
a title but no it's not yeah so that's
why i put it in in those categories
right something you haven't mentioned
um i i'm very proud of this every letter
has a title well i was going to say
every letter is a title yes
that was my next
yes and i'm proud of some of the titles
i'll tell you one of them okay
one of them a woman just writes in kind
of angry but i didn't put it in the hate
mail section i forgot what section i put
it in uh she was frustrated with me but
she has some
she has an african name
all right it's clearly african name and
is complaining that i'm carrying the
name degrasse with me oh angry really
angry it's like you know this is your
slave name and when you and you're doing
a disservice to other black children
coming up who hold you as a role model
on and on
and so because the grass is french
obviously yeah so i titled that exchange
keep off
[Music]
that's one of the titles that's true i
got another one my only other one that
was i think was clever and that's it the
two out of the hundreds
um
this is definitely in the hate mail
section
uh a little while back i posted a tweet
and i think i remember the tweet
verbatim it was
cows
are biological machines
invented by humans
to turn grass into steak
oh boy
okay some people lost their mind
and one of them was the singer moby oh
moby
lay it into me because he's a big he's a
big vegan
moby got really moody but
moby got moody on me wow and he replied
in his instagram he said uh uh
when you when you're when your hero tur
uh let you down you know when one of
your heroes let you that's how he begins
his and responded in meme in meme
language
it was there no no
sorry it was a full text entry in
instagram the youngans are doing that
lately right not just posting photos and
eddie says how dare you make light of
the unspeakable horrors he's a vegan so
yes and he's an activist vegan he's not
just a casual vegan yeah how dare you do
this tyson for someone who's supposed to
be smart so you sound like a sociopath
oh my god i was like whoa wow
you should have about that moby chill
well a third of his fan base said
exactly that oh yeah moby he's correct
just chill out you're on your high horse
about a third you're not on the horse
not on an actual horse calm down mobile
mechanical yes yes
but how did how did you respond to moby
i'm curious it took a while and i just
did again when i say i do homework is i
have some some fast ideas but let me
make sure they are strong yeah and
compelling within my reasoning powers
and then embedded in a scientific
umbrella well sorry to interrupt neil i
just feel like you've remembered new
york if you don't interrupt me i i think
you're not paying attention hey neil
shut up for a second uh no but it just
cursed me that problem a huge problem
with twitter and social media is that
what you just said is i think a very
rare way to behave on that with social
media most people are compelled by
emotion and i'm sure moby
was himself oh so what i do thank you so
what i did was yeah so you're absolutely
right i composed a much longer facebook
letter and i put it in as a note i
didn't say
cows were a machine in a traditional
sense i said they're a biological
machine
so that's just that's just being
creatively factual
by the way we did invent cows there are
no herds of wild cows wandering the
countryside right we invented them from
a now extinct or rock yeah that where
the last of which was in i forgot what
century by the way this fleshes out the
research that i do when i reply yeah i
don't carry that information with me but
i know the basic facts that we
domesticated a cow i don't remember when
it would have so i looked all that up
yeah from reliable sources and that
that it fuses my reply so that's the
homework that i say that i do for those
that need it so there it was and i said
the now extinct auroch there are no wild
cows so they exist only because of us
secondly cows don't really have much use
other than to give milk and to be steak
we just lost half of our indian audience
but continue oh they're sorry well even
in india where they're sacred they're
not really doing anything for you other
than to serve a sacred value yes no i
don't have a problem with that yeah but
to want to protect the animals in some
way
if we didn't eat cows
cows would not exist
because no other reason to keep them so
i'm just letting you know the day
we outlaw eating cows no one is going to
raise cows anymore right and cows will
go extinct and i also said that
um sociopath felt a little harsh
for
posting a truthful tweet well that's the
anger and that's the anger and of course
social media
foments yes it's i don't like this one
thing about you therefore i don't like
everything about it
yeah to his credit he actually publicly
apologized he apologized for
overreacting and i respected that then i
wrote to him and i said
i'd like to
print your letter to me in this
collection
with my reply to it can i get your
permission and he gave permission oh
yeah so he's a good sport yeah yeah and
and title might be movie no no oh oh
that's what started this oh the title oh
it is okay no no no no no no no i'm
gonna try it
you can have that
and then in the next printing movie uh
so the title of that one was don't have
a cow ah that's better all right that's
good that's good
um you what so yeah as a kid early on
you were interested in in the stars yeah
yeah it was nine yeah yeah and what was
it was it just seeing was it as simple
as just the wonder of seeing no no no my
parents took us all around to museums
and stuff when we were kids and
and i didn't realize they really did
this just to run us so that when we got
home we would all fall
dead asleep
later on as a as a parent i know that's
why they did it yeah
were you running around in museums yeah
of course i don't remember running a
reminder you can't run around all
museums but you can run around our
museum hayden planetarium and the
american museum of natural world
you can't break anything basically my
point is that they took us and we i was
nine when my first trip to the hayden
planetarium wow and i was hooked ever
since and it's i just saw the they
celebrated the moonlight landing uh
anniversary and i went this 50th
anniversary yes and the l.a philharmonic
played to the actual the footage from
the moon landing which i of course don't
believe in
no i'm kidding uh
and what
how old were you when that happened and
was that something else that fomented
your your life yeah i was i was 10. wow
so that might see i have no frame of
reference for that
you want some more framerate yeah you
know who else was around that age at
around that time was steve jobs and bill
gates
and we're all there at a very impressive
way they're a couple of years older than
i am but not much more
and
you look up
and there's the moon in the sky and
you've got a tv image and
at that point anything is possible yeah
i bet
yeah but i do talk about the moonlight
in my the opening letter to the book is
a letter to nasa all right of course
nasa and i were born the same week yes
and i love that it's not necessarily the
most celebratory it's oh right yeah i
mean you make such an interesting point
about it you talk to it as though yeah
yeah people
upon reading the letter wondering oh
this is not going to end well
yeah after they get through the first
half of it because the first half is
very nice you are building your stuff
this is the 1960s i find you it was a
civilian space agency but who were you
hiring
you were hiring military pilots
in a decade where war was becoming less
and less popular
all those folks were like test pilots
for the navy and the air force and
uh
you know sure
they were fly boys yeah and they had
these very short-haired coup cuts yeah
in a
decade where hero was getting longer and
longer in a decade where the broadway
musical hair
celebrated hair
and all of them were exactly the same
skin color
so nasa was not talking to me yeah in a
decade where the country was doing all
it could to marginalize
who and what i could become in life the
civil rights movement for goodness sake
and leaders were getting assassinated
and
camp campus unrest urban unrest
so nasa's going to the moon and your
father was at the heart of that yes he
was at the heart of that an active in
the 1960s
at city hall here in new york city and
by the way
the biggest city in the country
in the bloodiest year of the bloodiest
decades since the civil war
the biggest city did not burn
wow new york city
was quiet wow very minor skirmish what
would you attribute that to i think my
father had something to do with it wow
he was never in the limelight he he was
commissioner of the human resources
administration human resources repeat
that to yourself well right what is a
human resource is do you have a job yeah
are you employed and what is a riot but
the last the last act of desperation
in a life that is otherwise viewed to be
hopeless
so in new york there are programs where
people where the
city government reached out to the inner
city ghetto they were at the time known
that gave people hope and i think hope
is a powerful force operating on your
motives on your what you think the
future will be like so
i think my father programs he had
put into play
i i think had something to do with it
journalists don't write about stories
that don't happen hmm
yeah there's no article about the
non-riot that's true that's true but
since that's the first time i've thought
about it and how cincinnati burned then
yeah dc burned detroit burned chicago
burnt watts burned yeah
and so
yeah so that's going on and this is in
my i say this in my letter to nasa i'm
just frank with him yeah which was a
powerful way to start a book and and you
do address uh race a few more times and
it's ironic that he was in human
resources because people would would
presume that you were
in humans okay all right i see what
you're saying
and there would be these liberal yeah so
there was a couple of instances when i
was appointed to be director of the
hayden planetarium yes and we were
fundraising for
the rebuilt facility which became the
rose center for earth and space
containing the hayden planetarium right
so i'd be at these gala fundraisers and
uh they this before i was well known
i'd be known by title but not by name
and the administration would distribute
the scientists among the tables because
they we you know
don't you want to talk to the dinosaur
hunter and the mammologist and the so
that would made the conversation
interesting for the rich folks so that
they might donate at the end yeah and
there i was i was in a jacket and tie
and they'd never seen a black person of
any
important statue stature at that museum
wow at that time this is now
1994. oh my god i thought you were going
to say
the early
no no no no no no no there was never
anyone
so they see me wow
and one person
very liberal
is
saying
oh so
what do you do for the museum
i said i work i work here at the museum
yeah uh and they said what do you do are
you head of some human resources program
or some government affairs in their sort
of liberal posture they were trying to
accuse the museum
of only putting a black person into that
kind of a role right all right so this
is a liberal lens trying to be bleeding
heart liberty yeah okay and i said no
i'm an astrophysicist
and we are here to rebuild
the hayden planetarium and what was the
reaction well you know you got to be
polite at fundraising
yeah you can't be like i'm an
astrophysicist [ __ ] okay
mic drop no so
really it's
same [ __ ] different day yeah yeah that's
what it was the ending letter is a
letter to my father
in the form of a eulogy oh wow rather
it's a eulogy in the form of a letter
that i read to the audience during the
memorial service to him
and
in there
i
comment on
lessons i learned from him
from lessons he learned in his life
that were basically
like a baton handed forward not as son
listened to my next lesson just stories
he told about his life that were
freaking unforgettable
like he used to run track and there's a
friend of his
who
um named johnny johnson oh by the way
great name
so the new york athletic club is who you
would compete for when you became 22 23
and left college okay they only admitted
wasps
white anglo-saxon protestants yeah so
there was another club called the
pioneer club they took all the blacks
and the jews
so blacks and jews competed side by side
for the pioneer club against the new
york athletic club and other clubs in
the land oh wow so they're in a race and
johnny johnson is coming around johnny
johnson is ahead of another runner who's
from the new york athletic club and he
overhears that guy's coach in that last
turn saying to his runner
catch that [ __ ] okay
and what does he say in his head this is
one [ __ ] he ain't gonna catch
he just
and he extended his lead more
it just fueled him yeah it just fueled
him and so in that day
what today might be called
microaggressions yes in that day were
used as launch points to excel wow
and so when i was exposed to
microaggressions of of a softer variety
than he experienced the taxi doesn't
pick me up no one is leaning the head
out of the window it's still of the same
dna it's a state yes all has the same it
all smells the same i would parlay that
into
energy it would fuel my tanks to to do
even more in digesting it the way you
did and then responding in kind
it's led you to this place and and you
are now and i kind of have yeah
to
internalize that kind of
you know that those micro aggressions
and use them as fuel is really inspiring
yeah it's i think it's it's also has a
certain efficiency about it because you
bottle up then it starts affecting you
emotionally absolutely and i think in
modern times
that's what people are doing with
microaggressions microaggressions
against women against minorities against
they bottle it up or they get angry and
and i folded that back into my own
performance and and by the way i
hardly ever basic practically never talk
about race publicly the beautiful thing
about your book and uh these letters is
that it transcends race and politics and
wherever you were born in the world
however you feel the there is something
absolute and empirical about the
universe that you are trying to get at
the heart of correct and earlier in an
interview today i was asked what race is
my wife yeah right because she she shows
up very light-skinned in photos she's
white is she this or is she black how
did i ask that this just came out it
just came out it was a little a little
weird and i wrote her out
i said uh whenever i asked what race i
am i say i'm the human race yeah yeah
that's exactly actually got an applause
yeah but then the host said no but i
still want to know yeah
very funny but seriously
[Music]
who wins debates
it's people who have charisma
who have good vocabulary who relate to
the audience right and they make you
laugh and smile
why did president kennedy win the debate
against richard nixon yeah because
richard nixon was sweating on his upper
lip right and refused makeup
and
that's for girls and senator kennedy
went straight on in so
you can win and lose debates
for reasons that really don't have
anything to do with what is true and
what is not oh interesting yeah and i
don't want
debates to be
p to pivot on whether you were able to
construct a good enough argument to
convey the truth
something that is objectively true does
not belong in a debate
so debating someone at the top of it of
a
pyramid
as an educator for me is of no utility i
see i'd rather turn around and face the
audience
and teach them what science is and how
and why it works then he would lose
every follower overnight if i were
successful right well how does it feel
to have that power i mean there's a lot
of people no it's not no no
power is what is your influence over
others yeah knowledge is only power when
it gets implemented right its power went
in the hands well in your hands i mean
in your very deft hands i mean you were
able to articulate yourself and make
your case okay power was i told james
cameron he had the wrong sky over the
titanic oh okay
and the sinking titanic that's power
that was power what'd you say to the guy
who made armageddon
really [ __ ] on armageddon i did i did i
but no no it was uh there's one movie
from the 70s i didn't dwell it was
disney's the black hole yes yes
on armageddon all i said was
it violated more laws of physics per
minute than any other movie
ever produced across the universe yes
that's my that's all i said
it was otherwise an entertaining film
are you able to be entertained if
they're breaking those rules that you
know so well it'll be entertained if
they make no pretense of following rules
oh okay like star wars star wars yeah or
uh or mars attacks no you don't
criticize that's fairly accurate
when you were a kid did you go to those
were you a fan of those like star trek
and science
star
star trek i was i was a
i i became more of a star trek fan later
once i
was mature enough to appreciate the
messaging
and the
and the
the soul of what they were getting
across
you know each episode was really a
morality tale
but told in space yeah right so that it
didn't come across too preachy right
they were able to get across some really
important messages especially for the
times yeah especially for the time yeah
and of course that was the show with the
very first interracial kiss yes that's
right yeah but even so the plot line he
was like there was some force operating
and they had to kiss each other it was
not of their own they were forced to
yeah and i i interviewed william shatner
for my podcast star talk and i asked him
about that kiss and he was recounting
was it
by the way i interviewed both him and
uh lieutenant uhura uh nichelle nichols
at a different time and not forgive me
for not ramming which of those oh i know
it was michelle told me this she got a
letter
from someone in the south
that said
i'm fully against
you know
uh
blacks folks and white folks uh kissing
each other i this is it goes against my
soul and against everything i believe in
but if i had to kiss a black woman it'd
be you
[Laughter]
what do you do with a letter like that
that's harder to respond than a moby
tweet how do you respond to that thank
you oh yeah
that's very
that's very bigoted and strangely kind
of you
um
i i read that uh you were applying to
colleges i read that carl sagan lobbied
for you to go to cornell how how did you
two become a question but it's not in
the book um but that's a general
question yeah yeah he i didn't know this
at the time but the the admissions
office at cornell forwarded my
application to him i'm now 17 i'm eight
years into a love of the universe by now
yeah and you know i had a telescope and
i did astrophotography i had my own dark
room well my bathroom converted to a
dark room on the weekends so did mine
yeah for other reasons
just dark dark girls of the soul
admissions office recognized this
forwarded the application to him and he
then sent me a personal letter
inviting me to visit the campus
and he would give me a tour to help me
decide whether i would go to cornell wow
so i showed this to my mother said yeah
let's do this i took the bus how [ __ ]
what did you no
he's already hadn't done cosmos yet but
he was famous he had the best-selling
books he he was on johnny carson the
then tonight show making turtlenecks
famous
yeah
a man of his and the comb over all that
was of a style of the moment you were
emulating his luke
and so uh so i took the but he met me
outside of the building
and i looked back and it turns out that
was a saturday so he met me on a
saturday wow show me the show me the lab
in his office i'll never forget this he
sat at his desk while he's talking to me
he reaches back doesn't even look
reaches back to a shelf pulls out what a
book that he wrote didn't even look
that's him and then he signs it to me i
still have the book that's amazing he
reached behind i just reached it was
just hard to do it was a reach there's a
book that he wrote and i said that's
badass yeah yeah i didn't have that
phrasing at the time but if that was if
that had
word currency that's what i would have
said yeah mr single
that's bad
i wasn't that young i was 17. okay all
right you've gone through puberty
i hadn't at 17 so that's why i did that
impression
so uh and i and i said oh then it
started snowing
and
he said if you bus can't make it through
here's my home number get out call me
and i'll put you up with my family oh
and leave in the morning god and and
ever since then i said to myself
if i am ever
as remotely famous as he is
i will treat students the way he has
treated me wow wow and i joke about this
sometimes i i'll say my phone with
barack i said barack i i can't talk i
got to rock out at the door
uh wait what did you say to obama no no
i joke about this but i would say if
barack is on the line i say brock i
can't talk now i got a student at the
door yeah i'll call you back later and
then talk to the students that's badass
but but that's a that's how strongly i
feel about that and
probably what he wrote in the in the
book was to neil tyson future astronomer
so that's the sagan story right there
and and his his widow um is uh
hugely talented and hugely talented
she's one of those enlightened people
i've ever met wow and uh she in fact was
co-author of the first and second
and third cosmoses oh no kidding is that
can we pluralize cosmos will you my
cosmos yeah
so she she puts the heart and soul into
the science that renders
cosmos
you can't even
say that it's a documentary wow because
the word documentary doesn't rise up
when you witness the themes and the
images and the and the content so that's
all her all the way were you ever
tempted to study other forms of science
no okay good that was good next question
um how did you uh okay and what's up the
universe called me okay i don't think i
had any choice in the matter because you
keep saying nine you're very deliberate
about the your age was there a singular
event that you remember that yeah we
went to the hayden planetarium that was
it the lights turned out wow and the
stars came out and i and you were struck
and i was star struck yeah how cool yeah
and it would take two years i would say
before i was able to
affirm
that this is what i what i want to do is
a career at age nine it just feels good
to think about it by 11
i had an answer to that annoying
question that adults always ask kids
what do you want to be when you're yeah
and i said astrophysicist uh you talk
about living in a universe that's always
trying to kill us and i have to ask you
this because of your the reason that you
i know will use with this answer how can
there be a benevolent god if you had to
make it if you had to make a compelling
case for the existence of god how would
you do that
if you had to oh uh
so
uh
it's it in a sound bite
okay if you go back to ancient greece
and rome where you had polytheism
basically the gods were not
neither all-knowing nor omniscient nor
were they perfect
they were imperfect entities but had
power over you
so if you want to look at what's
actually going on in the actual world
it maps quite well into a poly if you're
going to go religion on it a
polytheistic religion such as what the
ancient greeks and romans adopted
mirrors very well with what's actually
happening
oh there's a store there's a tempest
whipping up in the oceans poseidon is
angry what did you do
and it's poseidon and by the way
poseidon has some quirky things about
him too
uh if there you could you can out locate
life's events good or bad to the whims
of gods i see the moment you went to a
monotheistic god who's all-powerful
all-knowing all good right
then you've got challenges right then
why then you have to ask why
the world are not all good right there
are bad things that happen to good
people and good things that happen to
bad people and not only that i'm not
talking about man's inhumanity to man
because that has been resolved
theologically
that there's evil in the world because
you need free will to on your own to
find jesus you can't be forced to that
so i'm just making the case that there
if there is a god
that god cannot simultaneously be
all powerful and all good if something
looks like it's not good that happens to
you
if your recourse in that moment is well
god works in mysterious ways
okay but you seem to understand other
things that god did you've made very
firm decisions decisions about them why
in this moment are you now saying you
don't understand it rather than saying
god is capricious and is actually angry
and evil why then neil would you say
you're an agnostic and not an atheist
i oh
you really want to know the answer to
that yeah okay
um
dictionaries
do not
define words contrary to what anyone
thinks about them
they describe words as they have come
into use
and track that use
depending on how many people and what
their frequency is and what official
sources uh you know they'll track the
new york times other sources of english
that publishers this sort of thing if
you tell someone you're an atheist
today
that comes with certain expectations of
thoughts and behavior we are in a
labeling society right where you've
determined something you've uh one label
you will make assumptions about the
person based on that label so watch what
happens interesting okay i posted a
facebook feed on my facebook feed this
is now
10 years ago um godspeed
to space shuttle 108 i forgot what
number it was
i got a friend on there fixing the
hubble telescope
people said
godspeed i thought you were an atheist
how could you use that word how dare you
you're an atheist
i must not be an atheist then
if if
my use of that word means to them i'm
not an atheist
then i'm not an atheist all right other
things ask me what is my favorite
musical of all time i was going to ask
you that what is it
it's jesus christ superstar
and i saw it in real time oh my i saw it
with ben vereen no bro that's all old
eyes he played jesus he was judas but i
thought you were an atheist
okay
there's no room for some hybridization
of that so i say i'm an agnostic
because if i say i'm an atheist people
will not fully understand how i behave
neil i i wish i had more time with you
but i'm i'm almost out so okay
my uh friend of a friend of christians
our friend doug goodman he's uh he's a
phys physics professor wanted me to ask
you this um uh what you think about
exoplanets winning the nobel prize in
physics they just announced it today so
we might be the this might be an
exciting uh first uh right comment so um
exoplanets we've got 4000 or so in the
catalog and it's a rising number uh
they've all been discovered since 1995.
okay so i think anyone who is 24 years
old and younger
i will knight them generation exoplanets
because they've only known life nice
with planets
in our star system wow uh the recent
nobel prize went to cosmologists uh in
physics and occasionally astronomers win
this and this year would count among
them we win about once or twice a decade
for for astro-based things uh one of
them is uh named jim peebles who was an
a cosmology mentor of mine when i was at
princeton i was a postdoc there so just
a public congratulations jim people to
jim peebles uh these are is so quick uh
what is your most commonly used emoji if
you use emojis i can't believe i'm
asking you this
you
i'm here to talk about a book with full
i know letters in it expressing feelings
ideas and emotions one of the letters is
calligraphy on parchment i know when i
asked this okay and i wonder what emojis
i know
what else okay it was a trick question
all right all right you want to go there
you want to go here i've never used an
emoji in my life
but yeah i will use the colon dash and
and right parenthesis great okay uh as
the smiley face okay not the head
explode but not the head exploding okay
but i will not use the actual smiley
face emoji good respect yeah it's
respect i just i'd like the characters
on the keyboard
i want to keep them alive i understand
if you could be a professional athlete
what sport would you play
yeah i think as a kid you always want to
be a baseball player yeah play baseball
you had a really great response to it to
a baseball player in there baseball
player asks he can throw 100 miles an
hour but he really prefers physics so
what should he do yes and what's your
team who's your team uh i was born in a
native of the bronx right so yeah yeah
okay if you could have one snack food
for the rest of your life what would it
be oh that's what it could be potato
chips potato chips yeah as god intended
them to be yeah okay okay pure pure all
right yeah yeah but with good old sea
salt potato chip a kettle cooked sea
salt potato chips none of this barbecues
vinegar yeah uh abominations
these are abominations they're not
getting into heaven what's you what's
your favorite movie of all time the
matrix
uh wow yeah good well and dare i say one
of my favorite tv commercials are yours
just oh no no kidding mac yeah okay
that's really fun
yeah i've used a mac since 1984. wow yes
wow although i used my girlfriend's mac
who later at the time because i couldn't
afford one yet who then became my wife
we still have that computer you guys
went to school together you yeah we met
in relativity class in graduate school
no kidding and you became relatives yeah
um if you had to live somewhere else
where would it be besides you you live
in new york now still i'd live on mars
okay
absolutely if you could have no no i i
think i would live in a place in
snow-capped mountains and i like the
tranquility of nature okay be it oceans
or mountains or or
or trickling stream okay just something
about the sounds of nature are so
different from the city that they take
me to a a completely new place yeah that
being said
i can easily go to sleep to the sounds
of the city oh i bet you haven't there's
no hesitation doing so yeah right well
crickets since cicadas keep you up and
yeah yeah yeah
um if you could have dinner with three
people dead or alive whom you've never
met uh who would you choose uh i would
say
um
jesus isaac newton and jonah park great
yeah who's your favorite or if it's if
it's a jamboree everyone who was a
potluck okay if it's a potluck it would
it would be everybody
who
bill and ted collected in their in their
machine oh great so we've got joan of
ours you got joan of arc yeah beethoven
so great so crates yeah joan of arc
beethoven so crates abe lincoln um
uh billy the kid that's right uh don't
forget him and and genghis khan rights
that's right so you're going to go see
the third one uh i'm guessing uh dean
pereso drove i'm worried about about it
but yeah oh now see anything ken reeves
says uh who's your favorite muppet
oh
yeah you know
ooh
you know we got to love elmo but i
predate elmo oh there's a late comer to
this i would have said bunsen honey do
for you no no it'd have to be big bird
okay oh great just big bird wandering
and
yeah yeah do you have a big bird you
friendly demeanor real big person oh
well thank you yeah thank you yeah i
couldn't relate to oscar the grouch
because living in a garbage can the
garbage can smell if you could have one
superpower uh what would it be it would
be to read people's minds oh yeah and
that way you can prevent the crime
before it actually happens oh like
minority i think it is the most
powerful
because by the way
when i grew up superheroes
stopped crime okay right now they're
fighting other superheroes right right
you know the ante has gone up and the
old days superman would just get the
criminals and put him behind bars the
cats out of the trees yeah that's what
they did and so if i could read mines
you can prevent the bank robbery you can
prevent the assault you can prevent the
car and
then there you don't have to then
punish the people after the fact you can
prevent it from happening before the
fact uh like by the way when i was a kid
i wanted to be oh you didn't ask me what
superhero would i be oh yeah well i
wanted to be mighty mouse as a kid
really because mighty mouse sang opera
and saved this damsel in here
yeah
so you can fly and have this big
powerful chest yes and so you wanted to
be able to sing as you were as i was
singing and i would be saving
the other nerds
because i was very physically able in
high school
yet i i went to the bronx high school of
science yeah which counts eight nobel
laureates among its graduates wow as
many as the country of spain in total
take that's spain
um
so i knew that the football players
would be you know abusing and pummeling
and bullying the geeks who had slide
rules and calculations yeah you did play
sports yes i so i i wrestled yes and i
was also a fan of martial arts and i was
bigger than your average person in my
grade
so
i said to myself if i'm a superhero i
will be protector of geeks wow and all
they have to do is have shine something
up in the cloud like digits of pie yeah
and i'd come running and then i just
kick ass
and
make sure that the the the bullies never
bother my people again yeah and and the
ultimate triumph was
the geek set became the people who knew
how to fix your computer beetles or
stones oh that's a tough one
it was beatles for most of my life yeah
listening back on the music i think the
rolling stones music
had more of an edge yes it just took me
to
extra places than the beatles
more primal very good word there so but
i had to mature into that revelation
until then it would have been beetles
all the way yeah last 15 years of my
life stones okay for sure uh what would
you want your epitaph to read if you do
have an epitaph i think you said you
wanted to be buried definitely and go
back to the energy of the world send the
energy content of the molecules of my
body back to the flora and fauna
from which they originally arose it's
really cool for the flora fauna that i
have consumed throughout my life
so when people say when you leave this
this earth no i will still be here
i'm not going anywhere i'm not going
here my energy will be in the tree in
the bugs
you say something i'm i think about
death often and you talk about it old
enough to think about death well
unfortunately god knows what it'll be
like in a 20 years from now but but you
say something very comforting in your
book about death which um that's in the
chapter on death and dying yeah a
chapter there about how lucky we are to
be to have even been born that our our
lives are most
humans who could ever be born
given the possibilities of our genome
right will actually never be born yeah
so as richard dawkins says we
who are alive
are the lucky ones because we get to die
right
if you look at death as a
as some sad moment
how much sadder would you be thinking of
the people who were never born yeah yeah
anyone who was ever alive for any amount
of time
for me that is the go-to concept
let's say you're alive when you have
terminal cancer you have
your childhood cancer you die at 12
these tragic stories children dying and
then you say
they had 12 years on this earth yeah
that's more than zero yeah yeah and most
humans that number is identically zero
so on my epitaph yeah
be ashamed to die
until you have scored some victory
for humanity oof
chills that is a quote from horace mann
uh educator from 20th century wow that
was beautiful it was a nice reminder of
just talking to such a nice reminder to
focus on the good i feel lucky to be
alive and i feel so lucky that i got to
talk to you today because you're
somebody i've admired for a long time
and i i can't thank you enough i'm a fan
of people trying to get a podcast out
there thanks for your interest and keep
it going we all love you out there god
likewise thank you it means a lot thanks
neil
[Laughter]
well
that
happened well that just happened is it i
think it's just that happened well that
so that just happened isn't it
embarrassing what if he's listening to
this we we should try to uh
i don't think he will be oh really let's
operate under the assumption that he's
not listening oh i think the opposite i
think we should
assume that he is i assume that he's
listening to this podcast oh yeah you
know how busy he is i know i know but
he's honest you hear that book you know
how many letters he writes people do you
think he's listening to our podcast well
what if he is i mean what i don't know
well it's not as if we're about to say a
bunch of disrespect no no no but i'm
saying we should if anything try to
class it up for him and uh that's what i
tried to do that's too much pressure
okay don't i wish you hadn't said that
and also he's so cool and down to earth
like he wouldn't care if we're if we
stumble over our words a little bit my
biggest takeaway is
what a great rapport you two had and i
yeah
i'm not gonna say this without being
insulting to you how do i receive it
without being uh all right
yeah we did
well it was obvious that you did it it's
not arrogant if you'd i mean it anyone
listening
i think it's very it was clear that
you had a good rapport it was like a
great
non-sexual date like i could have talked
to him
or maybe
somewhat sexual who knows who knows i
don't want to presume anything but he it
was uh god was it fun to talk to him i
just
i started getting like nervous when it
when i realized the time i know i
thought it was i just thought it was
going to be so much more formal sounding
yeah because and i think i pre-judged
him just based on his position and his
stature and
and i assume that uh his heat his height
his his his um hand size i i assume that
he would be um
just a bit not stuffier but i know a
little more serious a little bit a
little bit less affable he's yeah he's
he he was such an easy um a little less
loose conversationalized i know he's
very loose i know it flowed so it was so
easy again like you said i'm disarmingly
easy and i think it's a combination of
he is able to and again this might be
the this is the insulting part um
but i i i mean it with love is that i
think
he is excellent at
dumbing himself down a little bit but i
think you did a great job at smarting
yourself up a little bit
so we met kind of closer you met in the
middle yeah
why don't you meet me in the middle oh
god i hope he's not listening
in the middle
as hannah b would say you get that
reference right now
uh bachelor fan oh boy please don't be
listening you really met in the middle
but i think
uh
it's that's his
genius that's his genius yeah and we
were talking about this on the way when
we were listening uh to his book on the
way up is that he ha he's obviously
gifted scientifically and his his
knowledge is incredible but i i think
his real genius is his ability to
communicate
uh to
every everyone everyone a
seven-year-old's us
and and this interview this conversation
that you had with them was no different
you can even communicate with people who
are hostile
that's a real strength that's a rare
gift to be able to do that
that requires a lot of um people skills
i guess
like social skills i mean he has just
very highly attuned i know see you asked
where
he he got that from and i was so curious
about that but i i guess it's impossible
for someone
who has that ability to explain where
that comes from exactly i'm sure he's
got you know a bunch of mentors he talks
about that but
it's like saying to
you know lebron james how do you
how do you
make a no-look pass like how did you
learn how to do that or
it's like i think some of that is just
like his ability to communicate
uh to the masses
is why he is who he is i think and and
how how do you explain i know i'm good
at that i ironically the the ability
that ability is difficult to communicate
yeah like where that comes from well he
had a hard time even he had a hard time
communicating where he got that from but
it's i think it's
it's uh
the ability he has to listen and to
to know and he talks about this a bit to
know what people
uh are capable of and are interested in
and when like when he talked about that
orthodox jewish mother um of of the her
son had autism and
and he was saying and he struggled with
it it took him a long time to a year to
a year to formulate a proper response
but i think in the course of that year
he was uh trying to understand her more
and where she comes from and and
understanding your audience or the
person you're talking to i think is the
key element of being able to communicate
yes it's like it's not really worth
playing if you are lebron like playing
basketball with somebody if you don't if
you're not on the same court if you
don't know they're capable of right as a
basketball player yeah that's a better
analogy
i just refined
yeah i don't know why a court would
matter the actual playing space but i
guess i meant like what arena the person
is capable of playing in
um
that ability that he has to speak to
people without being at all
condescending i know i think that's a
very safe thing for people totally and
this book the book that he wrote that
we're talking we've been talking about
is a perfect example of that of the of
those skills that he has that that um
ability he may not be i don't know
enough certainly about astrophysic
physicists physicists physics
[Laughter]
case in point
how the hell did you talk to him oh my
god i i just realized like it was it was
a version of like will ferrell and old
school when he just blacks out
this
well the uh economy during the civil war
uh it was um i don't know enough about
astrophysics certainly not nearly enough
uh barely know how to say it um
to to determine whether or not he knows
any more than other astrophysicists but
you're right it's just it's a bit the
fact that he's able to convey this
information to people and he's such an
effective he's the best teacher that
i've ever i would suspect he doesn't if
i had to guess i would say he doesn't
know that much more about his discipline
than other people within his discipline
i would if i had to guess i would say
it's it's his ability to communicate i
mean think about it we don't know we
don't know uh no but also i put money on
it really he's yeah he was the head of
the hayden plan he is the head of the i
think part of that part of that is
because he became so well known
uh
wasn't he before he was known as a like
on tv and stuff thinks
i know i mean look he's obviously
i'm not
i'm not saying he doesn't know a bunch
of [ __ ] but i don't think he knows more
than every other scientist i think it's
his funny quote i'm not saying he
doesn't know a bunch of [ __ ]
hope he's listening i i i could be wrong
but i really believe that it's his
ability to communicate but here's the
thing this is one of many reasons why
i'm different from neil degrasse tyson
because he would never say something
like i could be wrong but here's some
dumb speculation
everything he everything he says and i
noticed that in listening to the book is
that
and in during your talk with him is that
everything he says is rooted in
fact yes he's convicted he doesn't
speculate no yeah like the moby story he
told oh that was great it was hard to
let go of because it was i guess it was
such a public thing they're both such
public people and to go after somebody
with that kind of a mind i mean i know a
lot of people do a lot of people i guess
movie is pretty smart yeah i think of
him more as existence sorry sorry i
meant uh oh oh oh sorry sorry
yeah moby i've been i'm sure moby's very
smart too he seems smart yeah he looks
smart
he does yeah it's really cool that they
made uh amends with each other and but
mobile allowed him to publish yeah that
was cool of him it was cool of moby
yeah or maybe he just wanted
some press attention or moby he just
wanted some president
his tweet about cows is perhaps
insensitive sounding but it's factual
and and after the interview we were
talking to neil a little bit about um
his
uh twitter proclivity and how
um he was very proud of how many twitter
followers he had but which sounds
douchey it does but but but it's cool
it's cool that uh he was able to
uh think that's cool you know it's
enough yeah and not to be like above it
or anything exactly yeah but he was
saying that his he prides himself on his
tweets being um
on his tweets not being time sensitive
yes so that you can read one of his
tweets and it doesn't matter what year
it is or what month it is right and uh
and but that's an example of how he
thinks that it it shouldn't it his
tweets aren't opinions or how he was
feeling this one day based on what was
happening in the news they're all
factual based and facts will stand the
test of time yeah which until they're
dispro or until there's no right until
they're no longer fast yeah yeah exactly
i just googled moby i didn't realize his
do you know what his real name is
mobinson oh how'd you know that i don't
know no it's uh richard melville hall
but melville i wonder if he got moby
because
yeah oh probably or because people
thought he was a dick
i bet that's where moby came from yeah i
just written richard melville hall oh i
in fact that's gotta be that's a good
bat that's a pretty safe bet yeah
i'd be i'm looking now i'd be shocked if
it wasn't so in uh in the beginning of
the interview you it started by you uh
complimenting his feet
one of the i think maybe the first thing
you said to him was geez you have big
feet
yeah well it's it's one of the it's one
of the first things you notice about him
in big hands big hands yeah and he was
proud of his calluses on his hands yeah
remember what those are from that was
from the way he no don't tell me oh
rowing yeah yeah that's right rowan
yeah he is very callousy hand and i had
to show him my callus from from drawing
it was a less good oh yeah on your
middle finger um
he you guys were talking about pluto
being downsized and
under your breath you were like oh and
pluto comes from the dog
and he think thankfully he he stepped on
your joke with his massive feet
uh
so nice of you to call it a joke
uh i know i know i knew you were gonna
catch that i uh because i could it was
such a lame joke that i couldn't commit
to it i know you kind of swallowed the
end of it
uh i can't believe he made the uranus
joke before you i know i mean to say i
can't believe it is such an
understatement i am shocked if somebody
had said before that interview okay
uranus is going to be mentioned
who of the two people do you think will
be the first
we'll make a joke about it uh what are
the uh what what
are the chances that you have if i had
to put a percentage on it yeah
uh
96
or 97.
i was very proud of myself and i
and i which makes me
like him more that he went there oh my
god
what a great thing i really like his
commentary uh on role models when you
asked him who his role models were and
he
and he said that he he picks them all a
cart
and i like that mainly because i think
there's something really
uh limiting about
relying on your family tree
for your for your you know to determine
your legacy yes it it kind of handcuffs
you in a way even if you're it's a good
family even if you're not impressed and
this is nothing against our family tree
uh in fact i really like
most of our older relatives but
but i don't want to be beholden to my
great grandfather and what he did and
what he thought and well yeah i mean
and i think we're like you said we're
we're on the luckier side of that of
course
and his parents sound very impressive
yeah what they did and father was a big
part of the civil rights movement his
mother was a gerontologist they sound
like very impressive people but yet he
didn't want to be defined by them well i
think what might solidify that mindset a
little bit more is if if were we to have
come from
an african-american background i mean
there's only so far back you can go
until it becomes one of oppression you
know and and bondage and we of course
luckily don't have that in our in our
tree but he does up until i mean yes his
parents were impressive and i imagine
his parents before them but at a certain
point it becomes they were owned by
somebody which is
incredible to think about that that
somebody is impressive and and
valuable for the world like neil
came from you know uh french
slave owners yeah well that along those
lines um he was talking about
the microaggressions that he faced
and how he used that as fuel to motivate
himself um
and i thought
i can't relate because i'm a privileged
white man but
uh i i
i started thinking if everyone who had
microaggressions befall them
if they all responded in this to to
those in the way that neil degrasse
tyson
responded to them
don't you think we would be able to
stave off the
robot revolution the robot takeover oh
my god for like thousands of years oh
yeah this it would be it's it's
remarkable that because he talked about
most people when that happens it happens
to them totally understandably they end
up getting angry and internalizing the
anger and the pain and they bury it yeah
but he used it and similar to how he
responded to moby i mean not to make it
all about that but but like it is he
received this aggression from moby and
rather than just uh lash out
you know as a result of it he
internalized it and processed it and
used reason to respond but but he talked
about in the interview he talked about
when he responds when he gets these
letters
he says that he has instincts he calls
them fast ideas in terms of responses
but he never responds right away because
i think his fast ideas are i don't think
i ever go beyond my fast ideas when i
respond to i mean i do i don't want to
sell myself too short but yeah you can
be but but he has fast sort of
emotionally driven ideas
but he says then he takes those and then
it filters them throughout how he
phrases it exactly but he filters them
through reason and science and then he
formulates a proper response that is
based in fact and science and reason uh
so that's why again i don't think we
would have gotten satisfying answers to
a lot of those more emotionally driven
questions yeah if i were i just imagined
if i were
just started like dating him or like we
met and exchanged numbers thank god
what a scoop what a scoop that would be
and we exchanged numbers and like you
know when you first text somebody and
like you're so aware of how much time
goes by until you get the text back and
it'd be difficult to enter into a
relationship with him because i'd be
very insecure about him
texting me back in time
oh that's a big feat though huge feat uh
i thought it was great when he talked
about it it's super interesting when he
talked about um
debate the idea of debate and he and he
said
uh he's not interested in debate because
and i love this quote he said
um
for me something that is objectively
true doesn't belong in a debate oh yeah
i love that
he talked about uh the nixon kennedy
debate and how so often in in any debate
the winner is going to be uh largely
determined by their charisma their looks
their
their um
they're not going to have a beer with
yeah how persuasive they are for but
it's not but but when you have the truth
on your side when you have uh objective
truth on your side
there's no sense in having a debate yeah
there's just something so you know
people use the term bad ass all the time
for him to say like i don't believe that
i need to i don't think i need to debate
because
what i believe is objectively true yeah
it's like it's pretty cool pretty cool
he's like above debate yeah i was a
little disappointed um that he you asked
him to make a case for
the existence of a
benevolent god
and
he didn't he made a case for polytheism
which is
yeah but not only is that not benevolent
in fact he makes the point that it's
certainly not that they're they're very
flawed these gods but they were multiple
gods but
i'm still curious if he had to like gun
to his head how would he make
the argument for the existence of god
yeah i know he well neil if you're
listening i'm sure you are
i'd like to know that uh yeah he
in fact that's that's one of the most
common
common
uh
things to use to debate
the existence of god or or the lack
thereof
is the existence of evil and
the fact that bad things happen right
that's interesting finally he um
he said the superpower he would want
is uh the ability to read people's minds
but i know we talked about this yeah um
right after the interview and we talked
about the fact that he seems like he
already does he already has that power
because just again i know we've said
this but his ability to
speak to
someone and and to know what what
they're capable of and what they're
interested in it's almost as if he can
read their mind well in order to do that
as well as he does i think it requires
being very
attuned to another person's
nuance social cues like nuances the the
way they move their face the words they
choose the
you know something as as
seemingly insignificant as like a hand
gesture now why did you do that he's i
think he's collecting all of this data
uh right his social data right it's
right and it's going through this
incredible filter yeah and he's just so
you're right i think i think he already
he has that ability as much as any it's
true i just i just put that
together kind of that it's almost as if
the way he perceives the world and
perceives people
it's it's almost as if he uses the
scientific method to gather data yeah
and he's brilliant at it and he's
brilliant at perceiving
uh nuance in people's uh
personalities and their approaches to
conversation and to the point where
it that's why it seems like
it's all it's almost like he's inside
your head because he knows what you're
capable of but i think that's him just
gathering data and that's what a great
scientist does they gather data and then
they manipulate it and they in other
words i i mean i think you're right and
i think that means we all have uh tells
i think if there i think if the more
intelligent species were to visit the
earth they would be able to they'd know
exactly
who we were how we were thinking why we
were doing certain things i think i
think human beings like if you are aware
enough uh can all be read you know
i i i almost get great i
couldn't think of a great poker player
so i'm like oh yeah um
[Music]
yeah with the sunglasses
remember
no he's johnny
who's the guy the great poker player
johnny
something wrong we saw him once in uh at
a gift shop in vegas oh that's right
that's right it was weird to see him
outside looking really sad yeah really
sad um like i love vegas coffee mugs his
uh he wants to be buried he talks about
that he wants to return to the floor on
the fauna uh but his epitaph he loves
the quote be ashamed to die
until you have scored some victory for
humanity and i thought
i thought holy [ __ ]
he has scored a he's obviously
scored a major victory for humanity but
i it's kind of it's kind of a high bar i
know for uh
the rest of us holy [ __ ] what about how
am i gonna score something from humanity
well
yeah i mean be ashamed to die unless you
score something for humanity that's good
it's motivational i mean it depends what
you mean by
victory and humanity yeah
is this podcast a victory
please this is good for humanity humans
are listening that's true uh yeah i know
that's that's really daunting god he's
cool he's
oh wait side note um we forgot to
mention
last week's episode i have to clarify
something and apologize to animal
uh because i misquoted him apparently
somebody on instagram reached out and
said right and they said um at the
beginning of muppets manhattan animal
runs after a woman and he's not
screaming boobies he's screaming woman
woman
which uh
i think is still problematic but maybe
less so we we had this debate i i think
it's
equally problematic i mean the word
boobies is more offensive than woman
obviously yeah but
uh woman is someone chasing a woman out
of a theater to
presumably
get her well that's your presumption
maybe he's one maybe he has a question
to ask her or he's he is using a woman
is a i'm using context clues
so knowing animals knowing animal i
think you're such an animal apologist
i think
boobies and woman are kind of it's a
wash i think
it's it's the action of chasing the
woman out of the theater
uh
pursuing her in that way i think that's
the inappropriate part i think it's
inappropriate less so than if he were
screaming boobies agree to disagree uh
so now
we'll end the show as we always do with
the letter
subject is pizza goldfish
hi justin christian i'm a huge fan of
the podcast and have been listening
since the first episode that's awesome
thank you i guess i don't have to say
that every time you don't okay
just wanted to write in to say thanks
for reintroducing me to the forgotten
pizza goldfish variety
after you mentioned them a few times oh
i guess i talked about them a lot i had
to go out and pick up a bag and they
have definitely won me over and
debatedly been better and debatedly
better than debatably debatably yeah
you're right better than the pizza
flavored pringles i've never had though
i don't think i have either also justin
can you please
share a little insight into working with
britney spears on crossroads my 90s baby
soul needs to hear a little bit of juicy
scoop on her peace love and pizza
goldfish forever kdc um
yeah every time i have pizza goldfish it
strikes me
how
how much better first of all how much
better they are than regular than
cheddar goldfish and definitely better
than regular you know regular flavored
goldfish are just like crackers there's
no cheesy element to it isn't it funny
that after that letter the thing you
jumped into is pizza goldfish not
britney spears
i feel more passionately about clearly
but although i like britney spears a lot
i love pizza goldfish um so it's no
insult to britney no
it's just you know you know how i feel
about she's no pizza culture all right
uh a little so katie wants a little
how did she put a juicy scoop um
it's not juicy you know i remember
actually this might be juicy gross uh we
we started doing like fart joke we were
in bed so the scene i do with her if you
ha for those few of you who haven't seen
crossroads
uh is a movie that came out in like the
early 2000s and i have a little partner
where i play her nerdy um lab partner
and
we have a plan to lose our virginity
together on the same prom night so we go
to the prom and afterwards there's a
scene where we're in bed
and i remember and at the time britney
was
yeah she still is a huge star but she
was like
everywhere i mean everybody was talking
about her and um
so it felt
talk about disarming when i met her in
the makeup trailer she was just so just
like sweet and normal and like a nice
like small town southern girl and it's
like oh hi you're playing henry and i
introduced myself and um
she was just it's so nice i don't know i
don't have anything really juicy for you
katie hot gossip
but i do i'm gonna make it to us weekly
but i do remember um
being in bed with her and i don't know
why wait wait wait wait well it's in the
scene
and uh
for some reason we were making like fart
jokes i remember making fart jokes with
her and she was really like game and fun
that's cool yeah uh
and and and i remember like her being
totally normal and then when we we go
outside we travel from like the set to
where the trailers were
we'd have to go on a little golf cart
she i could see her kind of ch
change understandably because there were
so many people and they were like
paparaz i mean there were all these
people outside outside the confines of
the set who wanted
her who wanted something from her and i
it struck me i remember feeling really
bad for her i remember thinking how
alienating that must be uh for this like
sweet normal person to have to deal with
this reality that
was
oh my god like it's just so different
but i always
yeah i always had really good memories
of working with her and um
i i always felt bad for for
how she was treated by by the whatever
media uh well save it for the brittany
okay oh my god how great would that be
it'd be great
um well that's the show uh that's the
show guys the show wow from neil
degrasse tyson to britney spears i
wonder if that's ever happened in a
podcast
uh thanks everyone thanks to neil
degrass tyson thank you for being our
most intelligent guest uh it's gonna
it's a high bar uh all like one of our
best kneels that we've had on yeah he's
one of our best three nils we've had uh
on the show yeah brennan and no offense
to brennan and patrick harris um so
we'll see you guys next week thanks for
listening life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
life is short is it by me yep justin
by you that's right produced by me
christian long justin's brother and
megan monaco god we are getting so much
worse than these guys right now i'm
getting worse
it's uh our senior producer is michelle
miche lanz and our uh audio engineer is
marcelino viopondo it's executive
produced by marsha louis and hernan
lopez for wondering
save it for the brittany oh yeah okay
do you hear that yeah these are these
microphones are so sensitive that was
such a tiny little
gas bubble
oh yeah oh my god isn't that crazy
listen
oh no yeah
yeah
so you don't have to get close at all
like this is good right nah
nah nah wow this is cool this is dope i
know i'm gonna
get these this would be a cool set like
a table like this yeah
what did you
[Laughter]
it's like pokey and coffee what i mean
what do you think's gonna happen yeah
well like every breath sorry audience
every inhale is like i know i know can't
you like almost like hear like your
cilia like the wind going against your
cilia and your nose
gross
i don't think it's called cilia isn't it
no it's nose hair it's not cilia cilia
is a is it um we should roll on this
this isn't that like a cellular thing
it's like it's like on mitochondria oh
yeah no cilia
i don't get cilia i think you have cilia
in your nose you silly uh you silly a
goose uh
i think you do right phoebe
cilia no
i think it's a cellular thing
i think it's nose hair i thought cilia
with it was
all right we'll figure it out we'll ask
the audience to write it
you